[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
votre magazine consacré à l'emploi et à
la formation professionnelle tout de
suite le sommaire des nouveautés à
skywest avec des créations d'emplois à
la clef fun landes propose des jeux
gonflables pour enfants y fait des
simulations de formule 1 de rallye et
des escape game deux entreprises de
loisirs et de jeux découverte du métier
de graphiste dans la start-up exode
games cette société d'édition de jeux de
société installée à montigny le
bretonneux est en forte croissance grâce
à son jeu jurassic world enfin
présentation de la formation animation
2d 3d spécialité jeu vidéo une filière
du campus troisième des lampes pour
l'institut de l'image et du son propose
des cours pour la création numérique
destiné aux jeux vidéo de nouvelles
ouvertures à skywest de structure
spécialisée dans le divertissement et le
loisir un espace de jeux gonflables pour
enfants avec fun landes puis un espace
de simulation réalité virtuelle et
d'escale game avec i way qui va ouvrir
début février
au total près de 25 emplois sont créés
suite à ces ouvertures les images de
mélanie poké et de jacques brun des jeux
gonflables pour les enfants de 2 à 12
ans bienvenue à fun landes
ouvert depuis le 23 novembre 2019 et
skywest au total cinq emplois sont
nécessaires au fonctionnement de cette
structure des personnes titulaires du
bafa ou de ces apps et petite enfance
ont été recrutés alors il ya des
personnes qui sont déjà de l'entreprise
et on a recruté en plus des personnes
qui sont titulaires du bafa et des crp
petite enfance pour pouvoir être
vraiment au plus proche des fonctions
pour nous le monde ici est de s'occuper
des enfants
autre ouverture prévue au mois de
février avoué avec ses simulateurs de
formule 1 et de rallye des défis en
équipe à travers la réalité virtuelle ou
encore des escales game traditionnel
avec une vingtaine de collaborateurs
pour la gestion de cette société
on va avoir des profils qui sont
différents on va avoir des contrats
des contrats 35 heures mais aussi avoir
des contrats plus courts parce que là le
grand public va vraiment se condenser
sur le week-end donc on a parlé des
contrats qui vont être des contrats de 8
heures des contrats de 14 heures des
contrats de 24 heures en fonction des
besoins
aujourd'hui ou alors on est en plein
dans la partie recrutement de ski et
accueille toute la partie animation game
manager on est vraiment sur des profits
de personnes qui par contre ont plutôt
cette logique de voilà de la relation
client ça c'est vraiment ce qui va être
au coeur du sujet et si vous souhaitez
postuler à ayew et pour les postes
d'animateurs vous pouvez envoyer votre
candidature à l'adresse mail suivante
start up en plein développement une
success story en devenir implantée à
montigny le bretonneux x games et
éditeur de jeux de société une
croissance boostée par la création du
jeu jurassic world en collaboration avec
universal pour développer ce jeu
notamment le métier de graphiste les
images de jabrun jurassique world le
succès 2019 des x games cette start up
spécialisée dans l'édition de jeux de
société s'est associée avec universal
pour créer ce projet à la clé le jeu
notamment distribué par asmodée a été
vendu dans le monde entier
vous allez créer votre faction
développer votre votre deck de cartes
pour constituer votre armée et faire un
scénario de que ce soit juste faire un
objectif ou alors affronter humains et
dinosaures ou incarner un dinosaure ce
qui est assez rare
créée en 2010 cet exode games a
multiplié par trois son chiffre
d'affaires les équipes sont passées de 3
à 6 collaborateurs marion a été embauché
en 2019 au poste de graphiste designer
carte plateau boîte elle travaille sur
plusieurs éléments du jeu de société et
par exemple aller chercher de la texture
dern dame brûler des arbres
de la pierre et tout assembler ces
éléments pour créer un environnement
on va dire logique et en même temps
assez esthétique t l'ancienne l'ancien
d'autres cartes et donc ça c'est le
nouveau dos donc j'ai pu créer en fait
il ya eu hier
et là en fait par exemple j'ai deux
trois petites modifications à faire les
éléments qui sont vraiment au bord va
falloir que je les rapproche un peu plus
du centre est la phrase en fait donc
d'universal pour
dire que on a bien les droits sur tous
ces éléments va falloir que je la
recentre en fait pour qu'elle soit un
peu plus visible
après des études d'animation une
expérience d'assistante de production et
un master chef de projet multimédia
marion a un profil multimédia polyvalent
n'importe qui peut devenir un technicien
suffit d'apprendre les logiciels saas et
tout le monde est capable de le faire
les créatifs faut avoir un certain email
incertaine imaginaire faut être capable
d'avoir de visionner les choses dans sa
tête et devoir déjà plus ou moins ce que
ça va rendre après exode games a lancé
aussi exode conception pour les
prototypes et des figurines 3d et exode
studio pour de futurs projets on a
quelques pistes pour développer si
certains jeux en jeux vidéo voir en film
d'animation
donc on essaie de toucher à tout ce qui
est vraiment le métier de l'intervenant
qui tourne autour du jeu en général ou
de l'animation et on espère que d'ici
cinq ans oui on aura développeurs un
studio de jeux vidéo présente marion et
spécialisée surtout normalement dans
l'animation et là tout ce qui est
justement gestion des jeux vidéo et aux
dons qu'elles risquent d'évoluer avec la
société
après il va y avoir de nouveaux employés
qui vont se joindre
on va augmenter plus stable qui précéda
train sur qui peut développer plus de
jeu en même temps objectif pour cette
start up dans les prochaines années
atteindre 10 à 15 % de croissance par an
c'est l'institut international de
l'image et du son le campus troisième
basé à elancourt
il propose aussi une formation aux
métiers de l'animation 2d et 3d avec une
spécialité jeu vidéo partant à la
découverte de cette filière
le
nous avons rejoint frédérique levy
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le responsable
du pôle formation jeux vidéo et
l'encours absolument alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous présenter cette filière
c'est une filière qui comporte plus de
200 étudiants dans sa globalité est bien
plus de 100 étudiants sur la
particularité jeu vidéo une filière qui
s'étale sur cinq années
alors cinq années la première étant un
commune où nous allons poser les bases
académiques graphisme puisque on est
quand même dans l'image donc on va poser
les bases et ensuite on va poser toutes
les bases techniques pour dès la
deuxième année
commencé à aller chercher le jeu vidéo
en particulier pour ceux qui sont
intéressés et on a une particularité ici
c'est en 2d ou en 3d vous l'avez dit la
première année consacrée aux
fondamentaux du travail sur l'image
qu'elles courent on retrouve qu'est-ce
qu'on pratique concrètement alors on va
pratiquer des cours de dessin anatomy
l'anatomie est intéressante puisque bain
dès qu'on va commencer à toucher aux
jeux vidéo va y avoir des personnages
souvent humanoïdes d'ailleurs on le voit
la même des petits personnages mais ça
reste des humains à 8 donc l'anatomie et
d'importantes on va on va faire du
dessin d'observation l'observation c'est
le dessin d'observation et une technique
qui va développer l'observation
développer
développer le la compréhension des
formes des mouvements on va avoir des
cours de volume qui vont même si on va
travailler sur des logiciels qui gère le
volume va faire du volume
quand par des nations avec de la terre
ça permet de comprendre le volume
plus profondément on va faire de la
couleur comprendre aussi la couleur à
prendre la théorie la pratique y avoir
des cours de direction artistique pour
comprendre que la créativité ça s'est
déclenché
et ça ça prend des cons à ses
fondamentaux alors on voit qu'on ne
travaille pas tout de suite sur les
logiciels
on apprend d'abord la théorie la
pratique vient à quel moment est ce que
c'est la deuxième année la troisième
année alors il y a de la pratique des
logiciels de base qui sont a pris dès le
premier semestre de la première année
mais la cd on va dire pareil des
fondamentaux logiciel qu'on va retrouver
dans beaucoup de 2,2 de profession et
ensuite bas de deuxième semestre
on va commencer à goûter à la 3d
notamment des outils
des outils numériques pour fabriquer de
la 3d et on goûte aussi aux outils 2d
puis ce que ben comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure on a des jeux de dés des
jeux 3d jeux 2d c'est plutôt disons pour
un plateau de jeu par exemple un jeu de
société ça pourrait être ça ça pourrait
être aussi des jeux qui sont un petit
peu dans un petit peu ce
cette mode actuelle qui on revient vers
des jeux pixels à rétro voilà le retro
gaming mais c'est pas dur et trop
puisque ce sont des jeux actuels
mais oui il ya un petit côté les jeunes
gens qui n'ont pas vécu cette période
sont en train de le faire revenir quand
on avance au par rapport à ce cursus
cette filière et qu'on arrive par
exemple à ce jeu vidéo
à quel moment on conçoit ce jeu vidéo
parce que je rappelle que ce jeu vidéo a
été développée notamment avec un
partenariat international que vous avez
avec un établissement à singapour oui
tout à fait ce jeu a été
lui a été fait pendant la quatrième
année donc ils ont donc le partenariat
c'est un échange d'étudiants
quelques étudiants partent à singapour
ce sont plutôt des graphistes qui vont
travailler soit sur des projets de jeux
vidéo peut-être même en animation et on
a des étudiants de singapour qui
viennent et ont une forte appétence pour
la programmation et ont grandement
accompagner nos étudiants donc qui
permet d'avoir un jeu et aboutie en
terme de gaming de plaisir de jeu
là on a un jeu qui revient un petit peu
sur deux principes de cartes donc on a
de la donner on a de la 3d pour la
partie ici qu'on voit visible ou
effectivement on a cette notion de
profondeur
et effectivement il ya un intérêt de jeu
qui a été développée par nos par nos
camarades de singapour n'a en
partenariat avec les étudiants français
d'autres projets alors là on passe à un
niveau supérieur c'est l'utilisation de
la motion capture oui alors la motion
capture effectivement nous avons nous
sommes un des rares établissements à
avoir un grand studio de motion capture
alors qu'est ce que c'est un studio de
motion capture c'est un grand espace qui
est cernée de caméras de capture donc là
je crois que le nôtre en contient 36
donc c'est vraiment et on met un on est
un comédien ou à la tête où on se croit
sur les images justement là on va le
voir sur les images on va mettre un
comédien équipé d'une combinaison avec
un maximum de capteurs les caméras vont
enregistrer ces capteurs la position de
ces capteurs et on va pouvoir retrouver
heureux de transposer ces mouvements sur
un personnage lui 3d qui est virtuel
donc on le voit finalement les étudiants
dans cette filière vont acquérir
beaucoup de compétences c'est vraiment
une filière pluridisciplinaire quels
sont les débouchés derrière le jeu vidéo
on a comme son nom l'indiqué on va
pouvoir travailler en studio des studios
des grands studios des studios plus
petit des indépendants
il y en a pas mal je sais que dans les
régions il y en a il y en a toujours
plus d'une vingtaine les petits studios
des moyens studio des grands studios
on va pouvoir aussi donc ça c'est la
partie intéressante et d'ailleurs nos
jeunes gens viennent essentiellement
parce que ils ont envie de jouer à ceux
de fabriquer ce à quoi ils ont joué mais
on sait que ces jeux là peuvent amener
vers d'autres technologies enfin ces
technologies vont être utilisés de
manière plus professionnelle on va
pouvoir faire des simulateurs on va même
pouvoir faire ce qu'on appelle du
serious gaming c'est à dire qu'on
utilise les techniques les moteurs de
jeu pour fabriquer des outils
professionnels de formation ou de mises
en situation
par exemple ça c'est c'est un des
éléments
sachant que ils sont formés aux jeux
vidéo mais les compétences vont leur
permettre d'avoir quand même une
certaine pluridisciplinarité voilà les
lits merci beaucoup merci à vous et puis
on va rejoindre des étudiants du coût de
cette filière
je vous ils accompagnent merci beaucoup
au revoir
[Musique]
quel est ton projet professionnel à
l'avenir pour l'instant je sais pas
vraiment où mme thiery g puisqu'on
apprend plein de choses et beaucoup de
domaines qui me plaisent et c'est des
domaines où il ya énormément de métiers
différents
mais pour l'instant je pense m'orienter
plus dans tout ce qui est le modeling 3d
[Musique]
je suis en train de faire c'est que on
mais encore 2
rigging et skinning donc ce qu'on fait
c'est que pour faire de l'animation doit
d'abord faire un squelette soin du
visage soit du personnage entier et
après on doit faire en sorte que quand
on fait l'animation se soit bien animé
pour que ce soit plus se réalise tout
cartoon si on fait plus un personnage
cartoon
[Musique]
après cinq ans de formation dans la
filière animation 2d 3d spécialité jeu
vidéo 87 % des étudiants trouvent un
emploi dès la première année de
l'obtention de leur diplôme
merci de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]